[Musique]
popularisé par le générique de la série
quelle famille avec Jeannette Bertrand
le galopant un des plus vieux carrousels
au monde pourrait bientôt disparaître du
paysage de la ronde qui fait partie de
mes souvenirs très enfouis de mon
enfance parce que nous on avait le
passeport expo 607 c'est sûr que ça fait
partie du patrimoine de l'histoire le
tradition
est-ce que la ville pourrait racheter ça
serait peut-être mieux qu'il reste là
justement le manège est en arrêt depuis
2019 et son entretien devient trop
coûteux chaque pièce doit être faite à
la main le manège doit être entretenu de
façon très particulière c'est à dire à
l'aide d'artisans
donc tout est fait à la main qu'on
cherche à lui trouver un emplacement où
il sera mis en valeur ça restauration au
début des années 2000 en vue du 40e
anniversaire de l'Exposition Universelle
avait coûté des millions de dollars
malgré les coûts que cela pourrait
engendrer aujourd'hui les storiens Roger
Laroche refusent que le manège soit
laissé à l’abandon
le patrimoine il n'y a pas de notion de
patrimoine ça me dérange beaucoup même
s'ils laissaient là il y a besoin
d'entretien actuellement il y a besoin
d'être restauré il faudrait qu'il soit
restauré à l'exacte la mairesse de
Montréal Valérie plante dit évaluer la
situation on va s'en occuper mais je
peux absolument pas absolument pas vous
dire en ce moment combien comment où
j'ai passé des détails encore mais
j'aime passer que la Ville de Montréal
peut-être avec d'autres partenaires qui
aiment autant le patrimoine que nous on
va se porter à la défense et on va
vouloir le protéger et l'installer
ailleurs après le départ de l'épitone et
du monorail voilà que le carrousel
fabriqué en Belgique en 1885 et envoyé
au Québec en vue de l'Expo 67 pour
équité les Sainte-Hélène ici Gabriel
prout Radio-Canada Montréal